[Music]
on this monday night canada's largest
province reports a record number of
covig-19 cases
the rising numbers in ontario spark a
renewed plea
we can avoid the worse and in quebec new
cases trigger an
elevated alert the new rules in the red
zone
ottawa's modified proposal for paid sick
leave how millions more canadians could
benefit
tax avoider in chief the u.s president
on the defensive
after his tax returns are exposed the
irs does not treat me well will the
revelations have any impact on the
presidential race
and canadian competition for the common
good our first and foremost priority
right now is healthcare workers and
frontline workers
the race to create more ppe
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
tighter public health restrictions are
coming to millions of canadians
as cobit 19 cases keep rising in parts
of the country
in quebec three hot spot regions
including montreal and quebec city
are now on red alert that's the highest
level in quebec's covet 19 alert system
the situation has become critical the
number of cases is rising
if we don't want our hospitals to be
submerged
if we want to limit the number of debts
we must act strongly right now
starting on thursday the three regions
will be partially locked down for 28
days
schools will stay open but gathering
places like casinos libraries bars and
restaurants
will be closed only takeout will be
allowed
as well people are not allowed to have
guests in their own homes
apart from a few exceptions here's why
quebec has the most
new cases reported in canada today 750.
in manitoba where 39 new cases were
reported today new code orange
restrictions are now in place for the
winnipeg area that means mandatory masks
in most indoor public spaces and a 10
person limit on gatherings
indoors and outdoors and in ontario 700
new cases were reported today that is
the most in a single day
since the pandemic began we will get to
ontario in just a moment but first to
quebec where premier lego held a news
conference late this afternoon
to explain that red alert and the new
restrictions
global's felicia perillo is in montreal
felicia
well donna late today the premier
announced that regions in red zones
for regions and red zones the visits to
other people's homes have been banned
as well as bars casinos movie theaters
and restaurant
dining rooms masks will also be
mandatory in
outdoor situations where two meters
isn't possible including protests now as
you can imagine
this type of confinement is bringing up
some anxiety for some people
the dining room at jukebox burgers is
quiet
customers are few and far between which
has been the case since
reopening back in june the owner says
another shutdown
would be devastating being an operator i
can adjust
employees payroll purchasing but i can't
the rent and
good luck now going back to the landlord
and saying hey there's going to be a
lockdown for 28 days and
can i reduce rent they're going to you
know blow you away montrealers are
anxious to know
how the new restrictions will affect
them i
manage sports installations arenas so
when you tell me that basically i'm
thinking hey you know
tomorrow we might be shutting down as
for schools though there have been
outbreaks provincial officials have said
they would remain
open even if a region moves to red it's
an essential service you know we can't
go to work and do the family at the same
time
while hospitalizations and deaths across
the province remain
much lower than during the first wave
experts warn that those numbers could
increase in the coming weeks
as the number of cases goes up and as
more and more people get infected
and if you start seeing outbreaks in the
long-term care facilities as we're
starting to see now
that could change very very quickly dr
christopher labos says the good news
is that we can curb the spread of a
second wave if people
limit their social interactions and stay
home
now i want to underline that most
businesses in red zones are staying open
as are the schools the premier said he
hopes these measures will only last
four weeks but he says he won't make any
promises
donna all right felicia parillo in
montreal thanks
the number political leaders and public
health experts are watching closely
with infections surging the number of
covenant 19 patients in hospitals
in multiple provinces is starting to go
up in the last week in ontario the
number of coven 19 patients who ended up
in the hospital nearly doubled
from 65 to 128. the ontario hospital
association says drastic action is
needed now it wants parts
of ontario the toronto region and ottawa
to return to stage two
that would mean a ban on indoor dining
and drinking at bars
and restrictions on other non-essential
businesses as eric sorenson reports
that's not happening yet
barely a week after the ontario
government restricted the size of
gatherings to no more than 25 outdoors
hundreds of people gathered in wasega
beach for a weekend car meet that
included street stunts charges have been
laid
but this may be just an extreme example
of a failure to physically distance in a
province with a mushrooming increase in
covet 19 cases
monday's confirmed case numbers 700 is
the highest daily spike since the first
wave of the pandemic last spring
and the recent trend shows a second wave
is here plus the ontario modeling
collaborative predicts the province will
surpass 1 000 cases a day by mid-october
ontario's premier says the second wave
could be worse than the first
we know that this wave will be more
complicated
more complex but what we don't know yet
is how bad the second wave will be
the reality is it's up to each of us
end of summer socializing may be partly
to blame young people account for most
of the recent confirmed cases
but the percentage is falling for those
under 40 suggesting cases among older
and vulnerable populations
are rising people have gotten very
casual i think at the end of summer
early fall and we've seen that effect
indeed hospitalizations in ontario have
almost doubled in the past week
the most alarming feature is the fact
that now we're seeing an increase in
hospitalization usage
and with the increase in hospitalization
usage comes icu usage comes ventilator
usage and
eventually deaths the province says
it'll spend 52 million dollars to hire
and train more nurses and personal
support workers
but the ontario hospital association
also wants restrictions in and around
toronto and ottawa
to target bars and restaurants and gyms
theaters and church gatherings
the province wants desperately not to
shut down the economy again
we don't want to turn back a stage
unless we absolutely have to
but if we do have to we will because the
most important thing is the health and
well-being
of the people of ontario a second wave
of covet 19 was expected in the fall
but experts are surprised at the speed
with which it's apparently arrived
eric sorensen global news toronto
toronto's top doctor is putting a pin in
the idea of social bubbles dr eileen
davila says people should avoid meeting
anyone
outside their immediate household
there's an immediate
rising risk in toronto of continued
and significant covid19 resurgence
what we need you to do is to think
carefully about how to protect yourself
as you go about your daily activities
alberta's largest hospital calgary
foothills medical center is restricting
visitors as it tries to contain an
outbreak of covid19
only pre-approved essential visitors are
allowed along with those involved
in end-of-life care there are at least
53 infections in the hospital
and four people have died across alberta
cases
aren't rising as fast as they are in
ontario and quebec
as heather urex west explains health
officials say the province
hasn't entered a second wave yet
a month into the school year parent
katrina snow
is feeling less anxious it seems to be
going good yeah there's no cases
kids are wearing the masks it seems to
be going very well
at a time when several provinces have
announced new restrictions
alberta's chief medical health officer
has lately struck a more hopeful tone
the threat of covet 19 is still real but
in this province dr deena hinshaw says
a second wave has not begun but in
alberta i don't think that
that's where we're at right now we have
seen increased daily case counts
for the last few months but those have
remained relatively stable
while ontario and quebec have seen their
numbers rise
exponentially since the beginning of
september from less than 150 daily cases
to 700 or more alberta has kept its case
count relatively stable
in the low to mid hundreds for the last
several weeks if we look at
cities like toronto or montreal they
have three
four times the population density as say
calgary does
so we do know that more people in a
small space bad news for a virus
but that's not to say things couldn't
change quickly
take for example the outbreak at
calgary's foothills hospital
contact tracers are still trying to
determine how the virus was able to
spread so quickly through these halls
there are now more than 130 health care
workers under quarantine
four patients have died and dozens of
elective surgeries have had to be
postponed
i'm not sure that i can say that it's
spreading within the hospital we know
that we have
more than one outbreak and we haven't
reached any conclusions beyond that
alberta is also struggling with testing
at seven to ten days it currently has
one of the longest turnaround times for
results in the country
which means if alberta was entering a
second wave it would take about a week
to find out
still for now there is cautious optimism
that if albertans stay the course
a slow and steady burn of cases through
the fall
would mean no businesses would have to
close heather urex west global news
calgary the canada emergency response
benefit the emergency payment to
canadians who lost their jobs because of
the pandemic
has now ended and the liberal government
wants to fast-track a new multi-billion
dollar federal aid package
it's made a deal with the ndp to support
it and that puts off any chance the
trudeau minority government will fall in
a confidence vote
but the aid package is still running
into tough questions in parliament
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is with me david let's start with
this liberal ndp deal what are the
details and what does it mean for
canadians
well the crux of the deal is expanding
the eligibility of the canada recovery
sickness benefit
and this benefit pays 500 a week for a
maximum of
two one-week periods over the next year
now in its original form the liberals
had a very narrow definition of what it
meant to be sick
how you would be eligible for it and the
ndp pushed to broaden that eligibility
to include for example the immuno
compromised or pretty much
anybody who's got the sniffles we want
those people to stay at home
and in broadening the eligibility the
ndp believe that
millions more canadians may be able to
use this benefit
people put their trust in us to fight
for them people are better off because
they elected a new democrat
for for standing up for them and just
and to fight for them
they can't say the same for
conservatives with the bloc they
literally got nothing
david what about the price tag for this
new sickness benefit and for the other
new benefits that will replace the serb
yeah we really don't know the answer
that donna and that's one of the reasons
neither the conservatives
nor the bloc were able to say they would
fast track
the bill that contains these benefits
remember there's three there's the sick
leave benefit
one for caregivers and one for the
self-employed
now the bill that has all this in it
does have a provision
that the liberals will be able to spend
up to 17
billion dollars on a whole range of
coveted related items anytime over the
next four months
with very little scrutiny and not much
detail and there is no answer on
how much each of these new benefits are
going to cost
one last question david both the
official opposition leader aaron o'toole
and the black quebecois leader e
francois blauschette have tested
positive for kovat19 how are they doing
well some good news on that front the
block quebecois leader belongs
he's out of quarantine he gave a press
conference today
and as for the conservative leader
o'toole he is still in quarantine but
he's
showing no symptoms and if that
continues he expects to be back in the
house
wednesday donna okay david aiken thanks
california's latest fire emergency
coming up
flames tear through wine country
there's no mercy from the wildfires
raging in california napa valley and
sonoma county are being hard hit
hot dry gusts known as diablo winds
carried embers into the city of santa
rosa overnight
that ignited homes that forced people to
flee in the dark much of the city and
its suburbs are under mandatory
evacuation orders
california has already endured some of
the biggest fires on record this year
climate change is driving temperatures
to record levels
across the state president donald trump
has always fiercely guarded his tax
returns refusing to release them even
though every other u.s president in
modern times has done so
now the new york times has obtained some
of his tax filings
and they reveal trump avoided paying
federal tax for 10
of the last 15 years in part because he
lost more money than he made
the paper says he's better at playing a
business mogul
than being one jackson proskow explains
what else trump's returns
reveal with his secretive finances
thrust into the spotlight
president donald trump is left insisting
he's the wealthy mogul he's always
claimed to be
they treat me very badly you have people
in the irs they treat me very very badly
years worth of trump's tax records
obtained by the new york times
show how he managed to pay just 750
dollars per
year in federal taxes in both 2016 and
2017.
he paid nothing in 10 of the previous 15
years
business losses drove down his taxes so
did potentially questionable tax
deductions
like the seventy thousand dollars trump
claimed for his own personal hair
styling
and consulting fees allegedly paid to
members of his own family
there are a lot of things in the return
that kind of fit the
typical profile of someone who is
evading their taxes who is illegally
paying too little
trump is taking advantage of many of the
tax loopholes used by
other wealthy americans for any other
person the story might end there
but the times reports the president has
421 million dollars in loans that he
personally guaranteed
bills that come due during the next four
years what could be trump's second term
in office
anytime you have a government employee
certainly at a high level
who owes a lot of money to some unknown
entity or entities that could be some
reason to put pressure
some leverage of the pressure on them
the mass of debts and money losing
trump branded properties call into
question whose interests
trump is serving while in office notably
there are no links to russia exposed by
the tax documents
but other foreign governments like
turkey have at times withheld business
from trump's companies
or lavished patronage depending on the
status of official relations with the
u.s
jackson is this likely to do anything to
shake up the presidential election
well donna just more than 35 days out
from that election polls show about
90 percent of eligible voters have
already made up their minds about who
they're voting for that other 10 percent
could be persuaded in part by something
like this
but remember donald trump has a
reputation for being almost teflon it
was this time at the 2016 election
that the access hollywood tape dropped
he went on to win the presidency
but donna expect this issue to factor
big in tomorrow night's first
presidential debate
okay jackson prosco in washington thank
you
british fashion label fred perry has
pulled one of its popular
shirt designs in an ongoing effort to
distance the brand from the far-right
group known as the proud boys
the company's black polo shirt with
yellow stripes and an embroidered laurel
wreath has become a de facto
uniform for the proud boys in a
statement fred perry says they have
absolutely nothing to do with us and we
are working with our lawyers to pursue
any unlawful use of our brand the design
won't be available
in the u.s or canada until a company is
satisfied there's no longer any
association with the proud boys which
the fbi labels
an extremist group still ahead 51 days
of protests will france mediate the
political crisis in belarus
french president emmanuel macron will
meet the opposition leader of belarus
she's urged him to help intervene in the
country's political crisis
people have protested for 51 consecutive
days now
macron arrived in lithuania today
svetlana tikanovska is in exile lair and
says she is the only leader elected by
the people of belarus
alexander lukashenko claims to have won
a landslide victory in august but
western governments including canada
have refused to recognize him
as the legitimate winner the opposition
and tens of thousands of citizens say
the vote was rigged
france and lithuania agreed today the
european union must decide on sanctions
against belarus
this week two beluga whales are enjoying
freedom after years in captivity little
gray and little white were captured as
babies and this is their first swim in
ocean water in years it's a sanctuary
off the coast of iceland
the whales who were sisters grew up in
concrete tanks at a shanghai amusement
park
they can't swim into the open ocean yet
but are gradually being given more space
to explore
they made the arduous 30-hour journey
from china in june traveling on planes
a ferry and a specially outfitted truck
next gearing up the race for canadian
made medical face masks
amazon is delivering thousands of new
jobs to two major canadian cities the
company is opening and expanding two
spaces in toronto and vancouver creating
over 3 000 new jobs it says
most of the positions will be in
vancouver where a major building
expansion is expected to be complete by
2023
and a new toronto office is expected to
be open next summer
a bc company is hoping to kickstart
competition for medical-grade masks in
this country
you may recall the shortages at the
beginning of this pandemic the anxiety
made worse when the american president
donald trump threatened to cut off our
american supply
as robin gill reports companies in this
country are gearing up for another spike
in demand
with a made in canada solution vitacore
based in british columbia is rolling out
n95 respirators
these particular masks are vital for
healthcare workers
in the midst of the second wave of the
pandemic we already have shipments going
off to health care workers right now
currently we're producing 1.2 million
masks this month
and next month we will be scaling up so
that will be
about 10 million masks per month this
type of protective gear must filter out
95 percent of particulates at 85 liters
per minute
to meet health canada standards
researchers at mcmaster university in
ontario
helped ensure the products met those
national standards
what we want for this for canadian
companies is to become
like the canada ghouls or the lululemon
where they have
a value addition and that value addition
is recognized
by the consumers of the product the
center of excellence in protective
equipment and materials is working with
about 40 companies at all levels of the
mask process
3m is launching its own facility in
ontario with production beginning in
2021
thus a mask race in canada these are
essential
needs in case of a pandemic like this
even beyond covert 19
i think there would be other viral
infections that will come on
on a periodic basis and therefore we
should be prepared for that in canada
v decor may have a leg up but it's aware
of the competition
we're just part of one solution that
canada has and the world has in
manufacturing these moving forward
business aside medical grade masks are a
critical part of the line of defense for
front line workers
as the pandemic enters yet another
crucial phase
robin gill global news burnaby bc
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's year
canada is the village of caslow tucked
into the mountains in the west kootenay
region of bc
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you